good afternoon
my name is manson garnier
i'm the director general of the ftth
council we're hosting this event and
it's my great pleasure to moderate this
session
before we kick off i just want to give
you very few information about our
organization
maybe we can move to the next class yes
the ftth council is a pan-european
organization
we have a mission to promote a full
fiber network
everywhere in europe our members range
from
vendors operators to investors covering
the full value chain of ftth in europe
and actually nokia the sponsor of
today's session is a very active member
of our organization
so this webinar is part of a series of
webinar
we are conducting uh on a recurring
basis
um
let me kill if you can help me move to
the next slide yes
and
we've had several sessions in the past
month the next one you will be of course
invited to join
will take place on the 2nd of december
and we'll talk about
the exploration of technology and
business benefit of disaggregation in
the pawn access network that webinar
will be sponsored by commscope
a few housekeeping items for this
webinar the session is obviously
recorded and you will have access to the
replay that email will be sent to you
together with link to the pdf of the
deck so
the deck you will which will be used for
this webinar all the slides used by our
presenter today
will be shared with you after the event
you can use the
question box on the
on the platform to ask any question we
have set some time towards the end of
the session to address this question so
do not hesitate to interact with us
we'll try and take as many questions as
possible after the presentation
now
you all know that fiber rollout is
accelerating in europe
today and this is something we are
measuring at the ftth council more than
50 household have access to fiber in
europe some countries are on track to
complete full coverage soon
while others like for example germany
the uk italy or belgium start with a
much lower level but are now extremely
have now extremely ambitious plan to
catch up and develop full fiber network
at record speed
at the council we see fiber as an
enabler
of essential application
and from this perspective it's very
interesting to understand
the different needs and to make sure
that fixed network make the most out of
the potential broadband fiber
thanks to nokia
this webinar will explain to you how to
make sure that fiber network address the
needs for more bandwidth more capacity
both for private subscribers but also
for enterprise and businesses which have
different needs
we will see that it is time to look
beyond g pawn and to envisage
xgs phone with 10 or 25 gig
bandwidth and speed we will also look at
the consequences of gigabit speed on
home connectivity how can we make sure
that
in-home wi-fi for instance does not
become a bottleneck
so these are some of the topics that our
two speakers will address
and i will now introduce
each of them starting with anna pesovic
who leads
fixed network fiber marketing in nokia
and has an extensive international
telecom experience having held various
positions in sales pre-sales and r d in
many european countries and i see
belgium germany portugal spain
uh india
and you were very actively involved in
several industry organizations
starting with the ftth council europe
where you've been uh on the board of
director and also the energy from
council at broadband forum
anna is a master degree in informatics
and computer science from the university
of belgrade so true international
european uh fiber
specialists
and we will be joined after anna's
presentation by gino dion
uh he's is located in saint john new
brunswick in canada
so i'm sure i pronounced everything
properly uh
genuine excuse me for that but you you
are
remotely connected from canada and very
happy to have you here you're heading
nokia fixed network innovation solutions
you come with 20 years or more of
telecom industry experience with having
extensively worked with many sea level
leader from network operations service
provider
mso worldwide and you also have good
experience of major web schedule
cooperation such as apple and amazon
and from a pure technology standpoint
you bring your experience in all aspects
of ip
video service delivery low latency
gaming optimizations advanced innovation
r d iot security to nano fuel but also
service insurance and cloud native
technology
so with that um i will leave the floor
to hana who will start with the first
section of this webinar
another floor is used
thank you very much vincent for this
nice introduction
it's always a pleasure to be part of the
projects of the ftth council
because
nokia was one of the
founding members of the council and i
myself personally have been involved
many years with the council so
i hope you can see my screen
yes so um
thank you
so today
we see massive opportunities with fiber
first of all pandemics has accelerated
new digital behavior we all know that we
still feel that
and
people are more at home doing more
things
that require bandwidth and more members
of the family are simultaneously using
bandwidth so we have seen that this has
changed the need for the service
providers
uh that
the
acceleration
to next generation pond has actually
started and as i will show later it will
happen sooner than we previously
expected
the second big trend we can observe
today with fiber is that the the
operators are increasingly saying fiber
is a unified infrastructure for all
their services so originally in the past
um
fiber and gpon were mostly for the
consumer segment
of connecting homes but now uh
there is a
ambition to use fiber also for
businesses and also in
smart cities five 5g world and so on and
especially want to
um
focus on the last one because the world
is going 5g but we see the 5g is going
fixed and maybe even better say 5g is
going fiber because
the
deployments of 5g will be very much
linked to availability of fiber until
recently there were a lot of discussions
in our industry what will when fixed on
mobile and every few years there will be
new technologies on one or the other
side that will
that will
encourage people to think one or the
other way but now we are really coming
to conclusion that we need both fixed
and mobile because they are a perfect
fit
and
five
g will
only
benefit from a lot of fiber not only to
connect uh more users to complement each
other in connectivity but
fiber is needed for
uh efficient transport so i was i would
also uh talk a little bit about that now
these trends that we see today are also
confirmed with what we see from the
analysts if you look at the
focus in fixed networks revenues you
will see that they are increasing for
them for the past few years
uh you will see that the growth is
really in all regions and um
and europe is uh is one of the biggest
areas of growth so that's really good to
see
and the next generation pond is also
accelerating according to the forecast
so it's really a nice
time for our industry a lot of exciting
things are happening
but
let me tell you a little bit more about
the next generation fiber why do we see
this uh disaccelerating
so we have
been doing always some forecasting of
the bandwidth
um we did it a couple of years ago in
pre-covert times we look at at the pond
with 32
users on a pawn
and then we have uh also looked now and
and covered times and obviously this
demand has increased
that's obvious because
more people are at home and more people
are using broadband
but
there is another thing uh since the the
the gigabit uh
broadband has become or becoming is
becoming a common marketplace
the operators need to ensure
that the users can have gigabit uh at
all times because they are paying for it
so of course when they want to do a
speed test or they want to download a
movie uh or
use any other
type of service that require a higher
peak bandwidth the users will have to
see that they have it
so for that reason operators are really
leaving the headroom just like a spare
bandwidth as you wish on a
on a pump so although the full capacity
of pawn is 2.5 gig in fact a little bit
less because of the overhead at the
exhaustion of pawn is happening at 1.5
gig and this is where we are
now
or that we are heading
to
and uh
what we previously believed would be the
date for massive
uh migration to xjs pawn is actually
happening three to four years earlier
and uh uh xjs pawn has been really
the
uh technology of choice to upgrade jeep
on although there were other flavors um
which happens always in our industry um
eg spawn has been adopted globally as
the technology to move from gpon
and
if you look at
what is the the value proposition of
xjspawn we can really
think it's a game-changing technology
first of all um it's a you know
competitive
um it's also uh disruptive
um it's a very good
one to uh
to use in markets where there are a lot
of cable operators um and operators have
been using that as a strategy but it
also enables the new revenues um it has
uh it is being increasingly used for
industry 4.0 but also for mobile
transport and we are just you know
seeing the
the it's only just tight it we are just
going to see more of it in the future
now
given that dx pawn
migrations has just started somebody may
ask okay
do we really need the next step
and the short question is
uh yes
there are needs uh for boosting the
capacity beyond beyond 10 gigabit
um
because fiber is not only about
speeds fiber is about monetization about
having more different type type of
services that will enable more revenues
on the existing infrastructure
investment now there are also some
debates in the industry what would be
the next step would it be 25 gigabit 50
gigabit or something else
we believe the 25 gigabit
is uh the best step
for the evolution um for several reasons
first of all 25 gigabit pound is um
very cost efficient and cost efficiency
is one of the mandatory requirements for
any successful fixed network technology
because
we are not like um transport technology
or core where you have you know we are
not so massive in volumes like we are
fixed networks have to connect every
user in every house and every street so
we're talking about huge volumes and the
only way to be successful in deploying
such huge volumes is to be cost
efficient now for 25 gigabit
pawn is using the components that are
being deployed today in
big volumes for data centers
they're using uh
the same type of
optic optical technologies and that
helps 25 gigabit pom to be more cost
efficient
uh the other nice attributes of 25
gigabit pawn is that for example can
coexist with g-pawn and exius pump
simultaneously and this is a very
important because operators
don't move from one technology to
another in one day
and this
these technologies have to coexist on
the same network for many years
um
and it cannot be that the operator have
to skip g pawn or skipping gs pawn or do
some kind of forklift migration because
the three technologies cannot exist
on the
same uh fiber at the same time so that's
not a not a problem of a 25 gigabit pond
the industry organization that is in
charge of uh standardizing 25 gigabit
upon technology is called um 25 gs msa
multi-source
agreement it's a group of operators
optical vendors silicon vendors system
uh vendors and so on um that are already
specifying or just published actually
the second version of the standard so
it's going really really fast
and they have agreed to uh make the
wavelength plan of the 25 gigabit pawn
in such a way that it doesn't
um
doesn't
um uh coincide with the
wavelengths of g pawn or easiest pawn so
all three
generations of technologies can
be together on the same fiber
but also you know what we can say about
25 gigabit point is that it is probably
the last technology that can reuse the
current generation of technologies and
lasers that have been used today so it's
a kind of a linear
evolution
everything that comes after 25 gigabit
pawn
will be a quantum leap in
complexity and in cost
and will require time to mature and be
readily usable for massive deployments
so a lot of research has to be done for
example in 50 gigabit pawn we will need
a new dsps a digi digital signal
processing because we are running at
much higher speeds
so there are a lot of technical
difficulties uh there is a bigger loss
there is a
dispersion and so on so all these
technical difficult difficulties needs
to be solved can we solve them of course
we can we're engineers we can do
anything but it will take time to
to mature these technologies and be
ready to deploy them
and in fact
once when we
have
the dsps for 50 gigabit pump
uh the the stamp 200 gig
will be very small because we are
crossing that quantum leap in complexity
so the steps from there on will be
already a little bit uh smaller
now
i have already uh mentioned the msa
and
maybe it's also a good opportunity to
talk about
um
the traction
uh in the market for 25 gigabit pond
so um
we as a nokia have uh already brought a
solution the commercial solution to the
market that has been tested by different
operators in may this year we even had
the first live network with 25
gigabit pond it was with proximos
and we have done many trials in um
more than 20 trial trials all over the
world
now this is a attraction that we see
with operators but on the other hand we
see that the ecosystem for 25 gigabit is
also growing and this is about the msa
the standardization organization that
has been formed roughly one year ago in
i think in october
last year
um and has grown um from 10 founding
members to more than 40 members that we
have today so this is um quite important
because um
the uh for for few things
first because 25 gig is driven by
operators is driven by the need
they see in the network and the second
is important to have this ecosystem
ensure
um the specs ensure the interoperability
uh and so on and so on so that's uh
really uh good to uh good to see
now let me tell you a little bit more
about the use cases for for for 10
gigabit and 25 gigahertz pump
as i said uh g pawn
has been around for
15 years or maybe a little bit more
and
has been predominantly
used for
for uh
for consumer services
what we see now is that the market for
fiber connectivity to enterprises is
growing um on the graph here on the left
hand side uh you see the the forecast
for the connectivity of enterprises with
different technologies and the ftdh is
growing now to be uh completely fair
many of them are still point to point
but we see that the pawn
type of connectivity is growing when we
talk to our customers almost all of them
are using pawn for
small medium
enterprise connectivity
what is now going to happen with egs
pawn and 25 gigabit pawn that also the
bigger
enterprises can be addressed and in
general industry 4.0 we have heard uh
examples from our customers
about
their business customers the
the from the agricultural sector
warehouse sector and many others
who are using the high definition images
and send them to the cloud for
analysis and real-time decision-making
and feedback
that this has been used more and more
because it helps to automate the
enterprise it helps to reduce the human
error
to speed up the process be more accurate
and overall help increase the
productivity of the of the business so
that's why the businesses are also often
willing to pay more
for a better connectivity um and
communication service providers can
leverage on that to increase their
monetization
on the fiber network not to mention the
offices 4.0 who are going to be one of
the biggest if not the biggest
contributor to a
higher bandwidth consumption
they need a high capacity connectivity
both in upstream and downstream and
there is also a third
segment which is a digital compass so
this is about using a fiber-based local
area network sometimes you will hear
talking about the pole or optical line
but this is also in uh
in in
increasing and growing um and
it requires already 10 gigabit uh and
moving towards the 25 gigabit capacity
so these are all
benefits for the enterprises but what
are the benefits for the operators
so first of all mentioned
monetization faster monetization
but also the fact that they can converge
or they have all these three different
type of pawns on the same network so
they can serve the right or they can
offer the right service to the right
customer with the right speed
and
having one
network
converged network for consumers
businesses and even mobile transport is
of course a more efficient more it's
cheaper to deploy operate and maintain
than having a separate dedicated network
for each of these segments
and of course it's always uh good to
remind everybody that it's also greenest
way to connect enterprises and this is
something which is very high on the
agenda and very high importance for the
both businesses and
communication service providers
now um i have been
mentioning a couple of times a
5g anyhow 5g transport so i would like
to expand a little bit more
words on that
now um
i think
every
one of us have heard about
the importance of fibering in 5g why is
that
well
because for 5g to be successful it needs
to have a
a good
uh
or let's say a very good transport
network the bandwidth is increasing on
5g the latency needs to be lower there
is a lot of changes from lte to 5g
now you have to do many things in your
5g network
um to have more cells
you know to
do upgrades on the core and so on but
you also need to
enable
a good transport network that will deal
with this
higher traffic lower latency traffic and
so on
there are different ways
you can do that transport and
carry
the traffic from the small cells deeper
in the network
but
pond is
the most cost efficient way to do it
and you know let me just say that
last year um
com dia
has
conducted a study
uh or rather a survey amongst operators
who are planning to deploy 5g
asking them what are the biggest
challenges of 5g
and
they have
placed transport as a number to concern
in 5g so it goes even before core before
cloud
and then the next question was what is
the biggest concern for transport itself
and their answer was cost because if
you're going to have these new cell
sites um and densify your 5g network you
need to
invest in this cells but you also need
to invest in the transport in connecting
those
small cells
so operators are looking at a cost
efficient technologies to do this uh
transport and pawn is a technology that
enables this cost efficiency because
it's simply already deployed where the
5g cells are going to be
this is uh on the left side you you can
see a graph from an
operator in europe who has plotted uh
their fiber deployments their
residential users their business users
and the future uh mobile cells and of
course
the the footprint is is is matching and
that makes it very compelling case for
fiber
because um you know there's no need to
invest in a transport network it's
basically already there so it's really a
no-brainer
and then uh ballots um have done um
a business case uh comparing comparing
total cost of ownership for different
transport technologies
including own point-to-point meaning
really digging um fiber putting fiber in
the ground to every small cell and
that's obviously the most expensive
option but it's here just for
[Music]
you know just to make a relative
comparison
and then they have
also included
other transport mechanism like for
example point-to-point dark fiber leaves
uh or point-to-point fiber leads that
will aggregate the multiple microwave
transport technologies
and compare that with pawn there are two
options for pawn you can either
do a capacity lease on a pawn or you can
use your own pump which is the case for
converged operators and of course that's
always the best case if you own the
fixed networks and mobile network and
you can make the most synergies
in this case could be more than 50
percent cheaper than other transport
options
but cost is not the only advantage for
pawn based anyhow
there are also um advantages for
scalability because
um you can add more cells as you
identify your network you know it's not
a problem to add more cells on on a pawn
network because it has a higher capacity
and also you can evolve that capacity on
the same fiber without
doing anything on the outside plan so
you can move from 10 to 25 50 12 200 gig
and so on um without
too much
investment
and the third
very nice
attribute of a pond for any hole is it's
very simple it has a zero footprint at
the south side
um
and
you know lower power consumption
so um
very easy to operate
that helps of course to be faster to the
market so not just
cheaper but also faster
with 5g services
and then um just let me end with uh
something
more more futuristic maybe
uh coherent pun
now
what uh what we are seeing today is you
know we are 25 is here over 10 is here
25 is here 50 gig will
will come
end of this decade
after that 100 gig so what comes next
but when we look at the the way that
today pawn is working where we are using
using the power modulation so we are
looking at the amplitude of the signal
so the high amplitude is one the lower
amplitude is zero and this is how the
information is transmitted in the signal
and you know we see that it's going to
be very difficult to use this same type
of technology the same principles
if we want to go beyond 100 gigabit pump
so there are other technology
options that are being exploited and
this is a coherent pond so it's very
interesting because in coherent pond we
are taking more
attributes of light so we are still
going to use the power the the higher
and the lower waves for for zeros and
ones
but they are they will be more
dimensions for example the phase
modulation
that means by moving the wave
back and forward
in a
in time
we can add extra information to the
signal or by using polarization um we
could
again add more information so how does
it work in polarization we would
actually send two waves instead of one
but they would be in a different spatial
direction so it's very similar to waving
a rope
so you can do it
up and down but you can also do it
left and right so
in coherent pond we are going from you
know going to three dimensional
signaling instead of one dimensional
which we had so far but of course this
is a little bit of a futuristic it's uh
still in research um a lot has to be
done but um it's one of the approaches
that will certainly that we will
certainly hear of uh more in the future
and then you know just let me close by
saying um what we have seen now is about
delivering gigabit speeds to the home
but that's not the end of it because you
need to deliver these new experiences
inside the home and make sure that the
high capacity pipe
that we bring to the homes can be
totally exploited inside
and with this i would like to pass the
word to my colleague genome who is going
to take us
through
the new experiences inside
the home so gino our
presenter
perfect
while we are transitioning the slides
sorry i just want to thank the
people who have already posted a
question uh on the question box and
encourage others to to do the same any
questions related to the previous
presentation also any question which
will uh
uh be triggered by uh your presentations
you know are muscular coming we will
address them towards the end of the
session thank you very much
perfect thank you vincent and thank you
anna for such an excellent setup i like
the way you ended things so we now have
this amazing bandwidth capacity
and amazing latency so how can we
actually
monetize this and actually make real
good use of it
um and why wasn't this done in the past
so that's a very good question and i i
think you're going to really like
what i'm going to share with you
with with the crowd today
so
one of the first thing to look at is why
is it that we weren't really
capitalizing on all of this bandwidth
capacity and there are some historical
reasons for this um you know even though
you know pawn and g-pawn has been around
for you know 15 something years as anna
said
uh cost was uh often an issue so the
focus was really on bandwidth delivery
more than anything else and the the onts
or donu's were seen as a big capex
component so driving the cost out of
that cp device was often part of the of
the equation for for the business case
but what if you could flip things around
now that we have a mature fiber network
now that we have all of this capacity
this is amazing latency
what can we do
to really you know help change the game
a little bit
so let's take a look at that why is it
in the past that this was really hard to
do well there's a couple of reasons uh
you know you had things like sock
architecture variations so different
onts would have you know different cpus
different architectures and operating
systems and that they made it really
challenging if you wanted to deploy
at what i like to call the ultra edge
and you'll you'll start hearing this a
lot more in the next couple of years but
the ultra edge is making use of edge
computing directly into the home
so stock architecture variations made
this complicated because you may have no
onts anyone used from a variety of
vendors
and it was really hard to integrate you
know applications or third-party
services on top of it
the second thing was real-time data
telemetry being able to get intelligence
from those applications or from in the
home was also very challenging now
there's excellent standards that exist
out there from the broadband forum and
things like that
but um it was always tough if you wanted
down to the second uh data from from
these uh applications you have to follow
funnel that through maybe an acs and
things like that
uh and that wasn't really uh really easy
to do at large scale that's changed now
there are some proper standards to be
able to do that
such as usb and tr 181 data models and
things like that
the third one service creation velocity
that's the third pillar that we as an
industry we wanted to address how
quickly can i launch a new service or an
application
well in the past that service or
application had to be bundled with the
firmware which meant very long
inexpensive testing cycles and that made
it you know really really challenging if
i want to launch a new service i'd be
looking at 12 to 18 months before i
could do it if you're lucky maybe six to
nine but even then six to nine is an
eternity in today's you know fast uh
fast world you know if a new tick tock
app comes out and you want to be able to
capitalize on it you can't wait 12 to 18
months you've already missed the missed
the ball at that point
and then finally lifecycle management
well we're all familiar with managing
the lifecycle of a firmware but what if
you wanted to disaggregate
the lifecycle management of these
applications from the firmware now this
means installing start stop updating
monitoring but really performing a
similar level of disaggregation that
we've seen in other areas of the access
network but directly into the home as
well
so those were some of the four pillars
of challenges but also four areas
of opportunities that if we tackle these
things we can really move towards a
model where we can quickly monetize
all of this bandwidth capacity and know
things like latency
so what does that mean well
we are now in a position where we have
service providers in europe or even all
around the world that are doing exactly
that
so no longer are you looking at the
in-home cpe as a capex investment or
you're looking at as a an arpu
enhancement you are able to
significantly improve the business case
for an xgs spawner 25 gig pond rollout
by
layering some of these value-add
applications things like parental
control home security service assurance
ultra low latency for gaming gaming
optimizations and the list goes on and
on so there's a multitude of different
areas uh and you know the the sky's the
limit really and what you can do once
you tackle these four points
so how do you do that exactly how do you
create a platform in which you can
address all of these various
opportunities
well
we're gonna talk a little bit about
containers
well containers have been around forever
in the it world this is nothing new in
fact uh maybe i'll show my age a little
bit but i remember using solaris zones
and containers you know 15 20 years ago
so it's been around for a long time but
it's not something that's made really
its way into the embedded device space
like a cpe
so in the past everything was tied to
your firmware your residential gateway
functions your applications which meant
all of the challenges that we talked
about long gone day cycles slow time to
market and everything else
but what if we could take advantage of
these containers to isolate these
applications from the firmware which
really means now that you have a much
faster time to market you can deploy and
build these applications independently
you can also secure your platform your
device so the abstraction layer that we
use for containers also provide the
security and the resource management you
know you don't want an application to be
able to bring down
your cp you don't want an application to
be able to be used to attack another
another container or something else in
the home so the
the container framework is really
advantageous because it provides answers
to all the points we talked about but it
also provides a security layer both
from for the firmware as well as for the
other applications
how does this look well
uh really it's it's actually quite
simple with this container framework we
are now able to deploy apps very similar
to what you would have on your
experience on an iphone or an android
device where you could go to an app
store select an app and have that
deployed in real time when it's in real
time it's literally 10 15 seconds the
apps the app gets
installed and downloaded and running and
everything else and we've done you know
many many demos and there are service
providers doing this today
uh you know some of the
early apps that we see are obviously the
the the ones that are most obvious like
parental control and and firewall and
security we're seeing speed test
application and things of that nature
but um we do have service providers
working today on creating a version of
appsource that would be available to
them and and really for this to be
successful it can't be done in a vacuum
so i'm talking maybe from the nokia's
point of view but
we want a very rich and wide ecosystem
so we need the
all of the vendors and everybody to
align themselves to really make this a
reality for the the fiber providers out
there and when we say
i
make this a reality is like for example
a couple of weeks ago you know we
introduced a variety of devices and omts
and gateways that offer this kind of
capability and sure of course
on the first release it's like anything
else you'll probably see this on your
flagship devices
uh or your some of your more advanced
onts and win use
but it won't be long and when i say long
i'm literally talking a year or two
before you're going to start seeing the
same functionality available on some
more some of the more cost sensitive
options
so some of the lower end devices if you
will with limited amounts of memory and
ram and flash and cpu they are still
able to run this container containerized
application maybe not as much maybe not
to the full scale
but uh
the the device uh environment is
really ready to be able to do this as
well once we have the devices ready it's
about creating an ecosystem
so for the last 18 months
we've been talking to dozens and dozens
of various
application providers in every domain
that you can imagine based on the
examples i gave you guys earlier uh
about now what does it take to build and
employ an application on an ont on a cp
that resides in a home you know how do
you do this
and it's not just about saying you
support containers it's really about
providing a rich and simple onboarding
experience you know training
uh end-to-end workflow testing and
everything else so once you create this
rich ecosystem
then the service providers don't
necessarily only have access to the one
app that they want they have access to
dozens and dozens of their applications
have been built and deployed across
other operators this is the same
strength that apple has when you deploy
an app to the apple app store it's
pretty much available on all apple
devices same thing with android
we're envisioning something very similar
here that when we work with a an app
provider that once they've done this
integration they can easily deploy this
across a variety of onts regardless of
what the stock architecture is
regardless of the operating system we
try to mitigate a lot of the
idiosyncrasies that come from that if
you remember those four pillars no sock
and an operating system was one of the
main things so providing an abstraction
layer that makes it really easy to port
to cross-compile those applications is
really key to creating a very rich
developer ecosystem here
now once we have that
you get to uh the point that i i'm
really excited about is really the
service creation opportunities
uh today we we have real world examples
of containerized applications for
everything from managed wi-fi from
security and powerful control ultra low
latency gaming packages we're actually
doing a project with an operator a fiber
to home operator in canada where we're
testing how can you monetize that and
the reality is
that the consumer base
is a lot wiser than it was 15 years ago
if for example you take a gamer if a
gamer has a 200 megabit connection fiber
to home connection today and he's having
issues uh playing in the home going to a
500 megabit is not going to make it
better being able to manage latency is
so there are services like ultra latency
gaming packages that provide the link
between the fiber and the wi-fi such as
vincent mentioned earlier how do we make
sure that the two you know get married
together we also have uh you know uh
remote worker sd-wan services working
from home is not gonna go away now for a
very long time and even when things
settle down hopefully after this old
covet crisis we're still gonna see 25 to
30 percent of the enterprise population
still working from home so it's really
important to be able to enable
enterprise services
in a residential context to be able to
monetize that access
and obviously you have your vpn services
service assurance telehealth remote
security
and speed test applications and the list
goes on and on and today there are
service providers deploying
containerized applications several
containerized applications uh
commercially it's been around for uh you
know about two to three years now
uh in in the in the space even though it
was in its infancy uh and i
absolutely expect that within the next
two years we're gonna start seeing the
first real app stores so you're gonna
start seeing service providers enabling
their consumer base to pick
today servicewriter offers a single
security application now you can
purchase it for
five euros a month you can get this
security barrel control well in a year
from now maybe they'll allow the end
user to pick maybe i want bitdefender
maybe i want sam security maybe i want
f-secure maybe i want you know a lot or
somebody else the reality is that you
give choices you increase your revenue
potentially increase your arpu and when
you tie
revenue opportunities like this
to a deployment like an sgs bond
deployment which can be you know quite
expensive
uh you can dramatically improve your
business case and make this you know a
lot easier to uh to go about
so with this uh vincent i think i'm just
about uh at the time end so if we're
going to keep some time some questions
i'm going to pass control back over to
uh
the the presenter role and
and we can go ahead
absolutely well thank you so much i
think that was uh possible
uh perfectly on time to give us a few
minutes to address some of the questions
we've been uh
i've seen in in the question box so
thanks very much for those who
who took the time to ask this question i
will start maybe with the first one
um which is about
the role of the itu
the only relevant standard body i'm
reading
and well when will the itu accept
25 g pawn
okay so that would be the question for
me thank you obensan
um
first of all that's not uh entirely
correct because there is also ieee pawn
so iqt is not the only one that is
standardizing and now there is also an
msa now i understand
a bit of
confusion because msas are not so
frequent in the telecom industry
until now at least but they are very
frequent in the industries that are
moving faster than the standards
uh like uh with web scales they're
they're much more frequent now what is
important to um to know is there's a
couple of things
and the uh um
the msa in the 25 gigabyte pawn is
something that was initiated
by uh the operators
so uh you know they saw the need and
then the
the vendors are following of course to
to help uh operators uh achieve their
business goals with the technology that
is best fit for that
um and due to uh different
political
uh reasons that itt didn't uh pass the
uh standard
uh which is very unfortunate and you
know something i don't like to to talk
about a lot
um what is important is to find a way uh
to go for to to go forward and the
industry has find that way through the
msa so
and
maybe as a last comment you know um the
msa is not redefining the 25 gigabit
pawn from the scratch this is not uh
this is not this is not the case um
the big part of the 25 gigabit pawn is
exactly the same as it was standardized
in the itu-t
because a lot has been reused there are
only a very small differences in the
physical layer in wavelength plane and
so on that the msa is
fine tuning and you know uh we have seen
heard from the operators they are not
really concerned about i2d so i don't
think that's a that's a big problem
thank you thank you and uh maybe a
question to gino you know what kind of
resources are required uh on the
the cpu for containerization i mean cpu
ram flash etc
yeah that's that's a very good question
and the um
the answer is it depends uh obviously uh
but the good news is is um
you can deploy containerization
technology and cps that are very limited
in resources when i when i say that i
mean maybe there's only about
uh two to three hundred uh mips cpu
cycle available maybe you only have
about 30 megs of ram and you know
maybe 30 megs of flash available those
environments are still suitable to be
able to deploy a couple of applications
that being said
some service providers are really
betting a lot on this technology and
it's not uncommon now to see rfps
or requests for
and when use that have as much as 30
gigs of flash available for containers
or eight gigs uh a ram available and so
forth so it's does very much scale from
the very low end to the very high end
and although you don't need a lot of
resources there's a significant
investment being made on irm
capabilities 40 years to come they're
not just thinking about what they can do
on on one gig or 10 gig they're really
thinking what i can do in five to 10
years from now on 25 gig as well
okay thanks um
i just want to acknowledge uh
one of the participants uh the surname
of rudolph who bombarded us with many
many questions mostly related to 5g
rudolph i think i will apply this
question past their home
past then uh to our speakers and and
they will address it directly to you
because they are not directly related to
the subject of today but i just don't
want you to to feel that we are ignoring
this question uh they will be forwarded
to
uh to nokia to be addressed separately
um
maybe um
you know um
what about um
you know again i'm reading could you
please put a few words on the future
roadmap for p2p active equipment
christian is asking us
go ahead anna yeah i was going to say go
ahead
yeah
that's a point to point uh active
equipment
so um
well if we uh i look at the
you know how much is point-to-point
deployed
versus pawn um it is really a huge
difference that most of the fiber
deployments today
are done on pump but nevertheless point
to point
continues to have its importance um
continues to you know have the
target services so um yes
there will be
i think the next step
is would be 25 gigabit as well
okay and maybe
i think you have addressed somehow but
the question is is still for you anna
i'm reading that the key drivers for 25
uh pawn versus xgs
um we expect that
25 gig will not be widely roll out
to normal end user i guess a private end
user
uh but rather to
to satisfy the need of businesses 5g and
backhoe
maybe could you just maybe
re-re-explain what you say around the
the segmented
usage of
higher speed
for the
yeah
yeah and you know maybe just uh you know
let me quote the president of bellaps
um the previous one uh marcus waldo who
have
said once that
you know in our industry the first
things come
um to
um satisfy the needs of enterprises and
businesses and then you know the
consumers are kind of a side effect
benefit from these innovations
um so maybe this is applicable here and
you are absolutely right uh to to make
the observations i mean
g-pawn is already a lot
uh a lot of banding although as i said
it's coming you know it's you know
running out of fuel but egs will
definitely be good uh technology for
consumer
consumer services for you know at least
end of the decade
but uh occasionally you need to boost
that speed to boost xjs pump to be able
to um
get business services you know the true
10 gigabit which is now the marketplace
for businesses because don't forget
xgspawn is a 10gb technology but in
reality it can deliver
something between 8.5 9 gigabit per
second because of the all overhead that
comes and that's absolutely normal
because in g pawn
you know it's not 2.5 gigabit it's a
little bit lower because of that
overhead so the the enterprises are
moving towards 10 gigabit connectivity
xjs cannot do that
you need to go with 25 gigabit pump also
the 5g anyhow you need a higher capacity
and these would be the first use cases
it doesn't mean that you know one day
i'm sure we will need
um
25 also for consumer
um services but that's not going to
happen in the next few years for sure
unless somebody comes with with a
killing application and you know
something we like to have at home but uh
history tells us it's not likely it's
unlikely to happen uh anything so
maybe phased approach um and if i bring
back the conversation to cpe
and professional gino i was struck by
everything you said around
you know
service provider considering
the use of app store uh for their
broadband uh solution i mean that's a
dramatic shift compared to
the strategy they've had so far are you
will manage to how do you manage to
convince them to move to this type of
ecosystem
yeah that's a good question so the
the reality is at least on a personal
level i don't expect that we'll ever
reach a point
where we'll have a a
wide wild gardening experience like an
apple app store or google android store
that's not really the environment that
we work in that being said
i do fully expect that service providers
will embrace the concept of app stores
and this wide ecosystem for their own
purposes uh so they'll be able to take
advantage of the open source community
of the
vendor community to be able to you know
quickly and easily port their apps using
it technology they've been familiar with
like containers and containerization and
operating systems like open wrt and
things like that so
yeah uh do i expect that it'll be as
simple as going to the apple apps or no
but
there are service providers today
investing a lot of effort time and money
in creating an app store experience that
they can monetize at the end of the day
it's really about being able to generate
more revenue you have all of this
bandwidth you all all of these
capabilities like latency
how do you make use of it now and and
the reason i say that the vincent is if
you have a fiber to home connection i
have a one gig fiber to hold at home
that's what i have i have it for the
last 10 years
and
what is my motivation to go to two gigs
you know my video conferencing is not
necessarily going to be better my gaming
is not going to be better but there are
things that this technology and this
bandwidth and this latency offers that
can be
utilized and monetize and taking
advantage of you know tying in the
latency from the five world to the wi-fi
world no extending a network slice into
a residential context extending right
enterprise services maybe you want to
create a slice in the home network for
telemetry offload for autonomous
vehicles maybe you want to do it for iot
appliances so there's a lot of different
ways and i think the service writers are
keen or wise to it they see what the web
skill and the ott players have done and
they want a piece of the action as well
i think you're on mute vincent
sorry
well thank you
um
[Music]
you know
thanks paul for this last comment we're
reaching the end of the time for this
webinar
i think it was great to see that you
know
rolling out fiverr is not the end of the
game uh it's also about uh increasing
the benefits you get from fiber via
developing and
new your technology on fiber and also
looking at what's happening at the edge
or the ultra age as you as you mentioned
because that is key to to maximize the
experience from from a user standpoint
i'm sure we will have more um
information to share with you i would
like to to thank the audience for
attending repeat that we will forward
all questions to our guests today so
they can address those who have not been
taken today
the replay is available communication
will be sent to each of you with the
link to that replay we will also uh send
you a link to
to get the pdf of the slide deck which
was used today
um so thank you very much for your
attention watch out for further
communication there are more webinars
coming
your way and we hope to see you very
soon on our webinar series thank you
very much and thank you for to anna and
jim for gino for
having such an insightful presentation
today
thank you vincent for the opportunity
and thanks everybody listening
thank you and goodbye have a good rest
of your day